i want to dive right into the kind of
biggest unanswered question
of season two jamie you become the
messenger of sorts with this cherie and
jesse stuff
um and you attempt to give them space to
have the conversation gets interrupted
by paula abdul um and then we never get
to have that conversation
before you came down like there was
something going on before your grand
entrance
jesse has another family
what
yes now she has two kids with this girl
called crystal and they were married i
don't think we should discuss this let's
pretend that this conversation never
took place i think
cherie to be honest
she was afraid of the truth and that is
how i
honestly feel about people choosing to
just
step away from things when they left the
show i was really disappointed because i
really
was wanting them to tell their their
story and to complete their story i mean
um
they signed up for this project and
trust me there were a lot of times and a
lot of moments where i wish i could have
just quit and walked away but i had to
pull out my big girl panties and
continue with the commitment that i had
made
um
but having said that i also understand
from a mother's perspective
from someone who has a family that your
natural instinct is to protect your
family so i have to respect her decision
um which i am assuming was in the best
interest of her family who has spoken to
cherie and jesse and where do things
stand with them now i bumped into them
in an event uh
one time and you know they didn't really
have much to comment on
even talking to me i think they're kind
of just waiting to see how this unravels
a little bit
uh because like i mean they were okay
with me but they weren't like the best i
just don't think they know what to
expect just like us at this point that's
all yeah
i think it was the same event kevin i
said hi to them
they kind of just like they just say hi
and then they kind of just walked off
and you know all i know is that she
unfollowed everyone and that's that
yeah
he didn't hear from me
i actually texted her i still like look
like i think there was a
tablet that wanted to know info i'm like
look i'm just gonna direct you directly
to her instead of me speaking on her
behalf and i told her like look like i
never want to interfere with family
issues and i have so much respect for
her kids and so i think she was so
grateful for that although she didn't
reply but through friends i think she
was grateful for that but um haven't
heard from him since
anna you got very close with sheree and
took little jadore under your wing what
did you make of this situation you were
the one who said let's not have this
conversation at my party but what do you
make of cherie opting out of the group
there's many points
i think it's really
what there's drama and drama and then
there's gossip
and gossip is what hurts
people to a degree that they don't know
to put jamie
in a situation
is very wrong and unfair
i think that
the question should really be
what was the purpose
not not changing the question the
question should be directed at a person
jesse has a wife back then when they met
oh really yeah she has he had a wife
yeah christian and jesse was married and
have two kids
you don't know about it no
i thought everybody know about it
because i don't have my family which is
not right because you shouldn't eat
you can be gossiping about people's
families and their kids that's different
than like
if we said something that we didn't
really really know about
about them so that it would hurt their
families i don't think so right so would
i have a problem confronting that person
not at all anna have you spoken to
cherie since she
decided to step away uh-huh and how is
she doing
good
okay kids is great everybody's good
jessie's good
yeah i mean i think it was very unfair
because
look
everybody has a closet
but opening the person's closet that
said this
before they go into somebody else's
closet
[Music]